hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the pro chess League
it's a game between Magnus Carlsen and
Vivid Gujarati the the bras are facing
the yogis and it's a game where uh
Magnus sees pretty much all the top
moves except the ones involving the dark
Square Bishop it's a true case of a very
very mysterious conditioning just known
as the bishop of blindness and here you
will see it in action so let's check it
out Magnus opens with Pawn to B3 yeah he
goes for the Nim Soul Arsen attack we
have Pawn to D5 and now Bishop to B2 we
have Pawn to C5 with E3 and now Pawn to
A6 so very standard stuff of the NIMS of
Larson attack this is the classical way
to play this and before we check it out
I would just like to mention that a few
videos ago I
um I mentioned that matters georgak
created a sort of a search repository
for my uh Channel there are over 3000
videos that you can search from and just
to give you guys an example
uh this is it I don't know if you've
seen it in the previous video so you can
search by by outcome by who played uh
what by by why what opening was played
you can even search by playing the
actual moves like you can move the
pieces here E4 E5 and it will find you
all the videos containing um
uh those uh uh those moves but uh now he
added something even more special look
at this you can write let's say Magnus
Carlson you you say okay show me calls
and games but now you also say uh show
me Carson games where white played Pawn
to B4 and you check this and then it
gives you all the games where Magnus
Carlsen uh played uh and uh in the games
worldwide actually played D4 doesn't
really matter if Magnus was white or
black but white has played E4 uh B4 in
those games and I've made 244 such
videos so absolutely incredible and now
if you guys are interested in all the
games where uh B4 was played you can now
actually uh check that out so just
wanted to add to mention that so very
nicely added by by matosh I hope you
enjoyed that as well now getting back to
the game uh we have Knight with three by
Magnus Knight the C6 with Fanta D4 and
now Knight to F6 we have D captures and
C5 already a very rare position upon E6
evident preparing the capture back on C5
with A3 Bishop characters on C4 uh C5
and now Pawn to B4 now this game once I
uploaded will also be added to that
Library where all the games were before
was played uh we have Bishop to A7 and
now there are some games where Pawn to
C4 was played but here we have Knight B
to D2 by Magnus and it is now as of move
9 that we have a completely new game so
vivid castles and now Pawn to C4 of
course it makes sense you do not want a
backward spawn on C2 and you want to
attack black strong Center the
characters Knight captures offering a
queen trade and just Pawn to B5 chases
away the Knight Knight Knight the D6
Magnus avoids a queen trade at least for
the moment and now Bishop to D7 and now
Bishop to D3 an excellent Square for the
bishop uh Queen to E7 attacking the
Knight and here Magnus just castles and
blunders a full piece here of course
that is a joke if visit were to capture
then I didn't just Bishop captures on H7
blunder is the queen so I imagine all of
you saw that so instead Knights the D5
now this definitely is a threat and
Knight back to E4 we have Rook f38
aligning The Rook nicely with the White
Queen Rook to see one and now Bishop to
EA then okay it's time to
move the queen you don't want to
overstay your welcome Queen to E2 now
upon the H6 that the G5 Square really
looks like like a white knight will
claim it so Avid has to ruin his King
side at least a little bit and you don't
want to uh play just uh any pawn move
like G6 or H6 because those Bishops are
just uh that's a weird Arrow those
Bishops are just exceptionally strong so
here we have Rook F to D1 uh and now
Rook 8 to C8 both players have fully
mobilized their pieces we have Ponte H3
uh creating some breathing room for the
white king and now Bishop to B6 which is
uh interestingly one of the engine top
moves uh I have no idea what it does uh
I I always imagine the bishop should go
to B8 to claim this diagonal and then
maybe somehow you you also try to
Checkmate the white king but maybe it's
with the same idea like B6 okay you add
some additional support to the d8 but
also maybe the bishop is coming to C7 so
uh does play what the engine says if it
should play we ignite the G3 now comes
Knight to F6 and now Bishop to B1 a
standard Bishop maneuver and this is now
a position of infinite potential you can
play this so many different ways but
basically white will at some point try
to trade his Knight for for night the
Knight on F6 to get his Queen to C2 or
D3 and somehow try to either Checkmate
the black king or Force Vita to create
even more weaknesses so Rook characters
on D1 if it wants to trade material Rook
captures Rook captures and Rook to d8
Magnus plays really back to C1 he wants
to keep the material on the board and
now King the f8 at least you know that
Queen H7 will not come with Tempo and
now Knight to E4 like I said it's time
to remove that knight from F6 we have
Knight to the D5 with it avoids the
trade and now Knights the C3 again
offering the trade and again Knight to
F6 avoiding the trade we have Queen the
C2 now preparing Knight the E4 and queen
to H7 and Rook the C8 we have knighted
the E4 and with it again goes Knight to
D5 uh the declines the trade but now
Magnus finds the very strong Knight to
C5 and the problem is uh you will lose
that A6 pawn and also Queen to H7 is
coming and um there's really no good way
to play this uh best way you can play
this is play Knight back to F6 and then
you just give up the
uh the A6 Pawn but with it accepted the
challenge he played Bishop captures in
C5 and now comes Queen to H7 so okay
with it is up a piece for the moment but
Checkmate is being threatened Queen to
h8 will be Checkmate uh the problem is
uh here Magnus actually uh uh Queen H7
is a fine move but he actually missed
the title of the video here which is a a
a mating three so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the maneuver that
Magnus missed here in this position uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on realizing that first
we sacrificed the bishop and then it's
Checkmate and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's the best
shop captures and G7 uh there's nothing
for you to do if King Jade Queen to H7
is Checkmate and if you capture on G7
then just Queen to H7 check King to F6
and now either Queen captures on H6 or
queen to h8 is Checkmate as the Knight
covers G5 and the bishop and queen are
completely controlling the diagonals so
this is what Magnus missed and okay he
played Queen to H7 is the second best
move it also wins the game but you have
to play it uh to absolute perfection so
Ponte F6 uh now uh giving the df7 square
to the black king and now Magnus goes
Queen to h8 with check with King F7 and
now he just wins back material Rook
captures on C5 and now Queen to B7
allowing the black king to start running
uh towards the queen side we have Pawn
to E4 attacking the Knight and the
Knights the F4 and now again we see this
mysterious condition known as the bishop
of blindness Magnus again has a
completely winning maneuver but he
misses it at the completely winning
maneuver is now Bishop captures on F6
and it it works because if G captures
just Queen to H7 check and you blunder
The Black Queen on B7 and if you capture
with the King either otherwise you're
just gonna uh face Queen capture Sun G7
so King captures and now look at this
Quinta f8 with check Queen to F7 and now
this Sensational Ponte E5 check which
opens up the light Square bishop and the
only move you have here is Knight
captures on E5 but now that you are
forced to play this the rook and C8 is
undefended you just trade and go into a
completely winning end game Queen
characters Bishop captures you're gonna
capture and C8 okay black will win a
pawn here captures captures captures but
after let's say something like this
um yeah okay you're down a pawn but
you're up you you you have a rook for
for a night of course this is completely
winning however Magnus misses it again
after this Knight to the F4 move Magnus
plays Queen to H7 and now vidit plays
Knight to E7 which is uh the absolute
strongest move and this move stops all
of White's ideas now you don't have
Bishop captures and F6 because King
captures and the Knight here is just a
beautiful Defender otherwise okay you
might have some Rook F5 check ideas but
with the Knight here none of such ideas
are possible so here Magnus tries Knight
to the E5 check as there are uh no more
ways to break through and visit accepts
F captures on E5 we have Bishop captures
and E5 threatening the G7 Pawn Knight to
the H5 defending and now Pawn to G4
threatening to kick away the Knight and
play Queen captures in G7 Checkmate but
vidit was prepared for this Rook
captures on C5 now okay if you capture
the Knight then the bishop hangs so you
have to recap run C5 and now just Knight
to F6 we have Bishop captures King
captures and now Magnus plays Pawn to G5
with check he still has the bishop and
the queen but all in all he is done down
a piece H captors and G5 Now Pawn to E5
check freeing up the light Square
Bishop's diagonal King to F7 and queen
to H5 with check with King death fate
only move uh that um
uh keeps giving with it a winning
position Queen captures on G5 and now
Queen to F3 uh bringing the queen uh to
help out with the defense and now we
have Queen to G4 offering a queen trade
but just Bishop to C6 this is how Vivid
forces the trade as Checkmate is being
threatened so Queen captures bishop
captress and now King the H2 Magnus
should resign this uh its equal material
if you only look at pawns but if you
look at pieces then you see that with it
is up a full night and this is resigns
but both players are very low on the
clock I think that it was around 10
seconds on the clock Magnus uh maybe 30
seconds or even a full minute uh but
still up a piece you have increment
you're not going to lose this so here at
Knight the C6 with King to G3 Bishop to
D5 Ponte F4 with King to E7 and now King
to F2 we have Knight day five Ponte H4
and now just Knight to the C4 the pawn
and A3 cannot be defended with Bishop to
D3 in Knight captures and A3 now with it
even grabs the Pawn King E3 with Ponte
A5 and now King to D4 with Bishop to C6
and now Pawn to H5 Magnus is pushing
those pawns uh there's just no way to
actually break through here this Pawn is
on a dark Square so you don't really
care what white does Pawn to B4 uh we
have Pawn to F5 captures captures uh and
now Pawn to A4 we have Pawn to E6
again no way to break through the dark
squares uh Pawn to B3 King to C3 and now
just Knight to B5 with check King to B4
and now Knight to D4 and he was in this
position animal 58 uh that Magnus
Carlsen resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once you
make a move as the bishop is attacked
also you have to keep the bishop and
this diagonal to cover B1 otherwise just
uh b2b1 Queen so you have to move the
bishop somewhere but then you blunder
the not blunder but you have to give up
D6 spawn now you're down too much
material you have nothing here and it's
it would be just pointless to continue
so of course after Knight the D4 Magnus
resigned and a wonderful victory for uh
virit Gujarati in the in the final round
of the clash between the the Bros and
the yogis so really incredible where
Magnus uh he he really had everything
and it was it was all over he he set it
up very nicely with the with with The
Bishop's pair here and he uh had the
attack everything was perfectly fine and
then although he could have defended
maybe with Knight to F6 it would still
be hard but after Bishop captures on C6
he just allows Magnus uh forced mating
three which Magnus
which Magnus missed uh but uh this or
this and then we said the the other time
here after this Knight to F4 move was
played again Bishop captures on F6
Magnus misses it again so uh incredible
that twice in one game you would you
would miss a a a capture with this dark
Square Bishop but that's why I call it
the the case of of the bishop blindness
the the BB
uh so yeah uh that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh I would like to thank
Savage Veena here Joyce Roseman a
larcetism and uh Thomas and Philip
maltos for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the pro chess
link and whatever else happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and do check out the repository
first link in the description below you
can check out all the games where B4 was
played uh absolutely incredible uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day